[Applaudissements]
on va enlever la ronde pour l'instant
merci mon chéri la roue qui reviendra
tout à l'heure vous savez que quand il
ya une roue c'est jamais bon sinon
attendent également la coiffure de kelly
aujourd'hui puisque vous savez que kelly
a été remplacé par lucas le fils de
pascal c'est un hasard totalité dans le
public il avait eu un physique atypique
et on a tout de suite collé tous les
deux qu'il avait une coiffure bizarre et
je me suis souvent demandé si j'allais
emmené mon fils un enregistrement jamais
n'ont qu'à venir et peut venir à venir
aujourd'hui que les quatre tirs on va
rappeler des cafetières jean-luc
s'intéresse à tout ce qui se passe en
off dans l'émission pendant les pubs
pendant qu'il ya des images qui passent
pendant que vous parlez entre vous 1
voilà tout ça et jean luc qui le
décrypte et ça c'est ça parce que ça
c'est fort babu qui s'est mouché riz
blanc parce que des fois il ya besoin de
décrypter à bari ne font pas tout tout
de suite
non c'est vrai une question moi je veux
bien aller allons-y quelle darija
bonjour je m'appelle nadine je regarde
uniquement votre émission pour maxime
gainey quand je trouve que les autres
chroniqueurs sont vraiment des veaux
donc ma question est simple yat il un
moyen de le pêcher au
merci beaucoup pour tout les
chroniqueurs nadine et et oui je pense
qu'il est possible de pécho maxime après
une bonne petite soirée arrosée au jus
de fruits bio il peut très vite être
pompée il ya encore deux mois il aura
préféré reste habillez-vous pendant
quatre cinq ans il sort de faire
connaissance mais il faut le reconnaître
maxime a changé je pense que acérées qui
a changé les dates c'est pourquoi dit
son prime évidemment à cause de son
travail depuis qu'il a fait plus de 700
morts
jean-michel vient de quitter l'émission
quoi qu'est ce que vous avez voulu
rappeler les connards qu'est-ce qu'il ya
certains c'était tellement chaud et sens
à leur trône à l'entrée gémir mathieu et
c'est toujours quelque chose qui me qui
me fallait que non mais ça m'angoisse
excellent idiot il est très à cheval sur
l'hygiène c'est ce que tu avais dit un
jour à cheval elle avait tourné avec
malik bentalha actuellement et le film
va être fou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
gérald des modes et avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les bailleurs
elle est sexy très sexy même des
quartiers entiers à craquer je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé et ça y est je me
suis bien en cette émission je le vis à
100%
vivez loi 100 % va vraiment vous êtes
excellent depuis le début de l'année je
pense que d'être à côté de jean-michel
ça eu une mauvaise influence parce
qu'ils sont cuits et chemise les deux là
je sais pas ce qui est au courant mais
maxime est devenu le manager du sniper
officiel de tpm pea je vais sûr que
c'est vrai on commence déjà à penser aux
produits dérivés
les deux ensembles mon dieu là on est
dans le top du top du show business
[Musique]
c'est redondant content quand j'achète
en temps pendant cinq ans
ouais
[Musique]
plus fort
les deux fondateurs est vraiment deux
heures mais j'ai dû rapprocher au plus
haut avec sa mâchoire d'un projet
voulais vraiment créer à nouveau
ensemble
non non pas du tout a été dit la vérité
parce qu'on a tous les offres donc jean
maxime même quand on a parlé à rome en
battant il ya trois semaines après les
quais tiers jean michel a continué son
délire donc il a parlé son projet à
benjamin regarder le bois nourrissent
blessé c'est champagne
rexel sa souffrance à une fille qui
dégage toi j'ai craqué tout le monde qui
veut qu'on ne supprime pas les détritus
mais la confiance jean michel et se
permet de juger tout le monde même le
patron away ah oui oui à la tuque peu la
leaf aucune les semaines ça commence par
un rire et puis après un regard des gens
plutôt que quelqu'un débrancher les
appareils
c'est alors nous c'est ce qu'on a fait
moi c'est dans le docu pour du bétail
juste avant cette émission mais bon on
enlevait aussi les prix ce qu'elle nous
coûte très cher en bauchi
elle est un peu ça s'appelle un strike
ça m'a choqué ça va choquer non mais
bien soutenu dans cette équipe niveau
soutient pas aussi compter sur moctar
bah oui là a bien sûr alors c'est très
furtif et ça m'a fait rire se croit
bernard montiel étaient déguisés en du
pont de du point du pont je vais vous
dire la vérité était pas fan du costume
donc à la pause publicitaire il est
parti en râlant il est tombé sur mokhtar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non peut-être veut me dire un truc rsa
ça te va hyper bien beau cadeau c'est
bien résumé évoqua alors tant qu'on est
dans l'envers du décor est ce que vous
voulez un de vos petits secrets de
fabrication des pmp vous savez quand
j'explique la petite histoire qui se
cache derrière une image diffusée à
l'antenne alors ils datent un peu speed
mais je pouvais pas le garder pour moi
ce jour-là agathe et julien courbet
avait dansé un slow sûr j'ai encore rêvé
d'elle je l' ai rêvé si fort
les drass s'en souviennent
seacom
mystère
c'est facile
nous seuls
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
je l'allaité anti-flou passer sa
compagnie tarbes à kevin après qu il
était coté de spécial j'ai pas osé te
demandes ce soir je suis sûr essayer
tout cas gasquet comparaît cet objet
dans la suite des affirmations sur les
habite et où dit-il c'est vrai aussi
c'est faux est-ce que vous avez compris
le jeu c'est con
[Musique]
jean-michel oui non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai vu partout
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on a une femme qui a accepté jusqu'au
bout ces deux situations et qui est
passé de la préférée des français
il révèle un mage houasnia et qui
maintenant est voué aux gémonies et lé
[Musique]
sait les dernières questions ou à tour
trouvé ma gloire ce week end
oui voilà ces bons jaillissements la
rugosité pmp de matin ça m'arrangerait
en termes de ne pas non mais franchement
on a cartonné vous avez même pas bien
vous n'avez pas besoin de ça merci sais
pas mais je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
imaginer que ça peut s'arrêter cette
émission du 10 apa - complètement moi la
matière me plaît matières fécales
[Rires]
le chantage au sculpteur
le calme mais quoi non mais n'était pas
comme ça l'an dernier bah j'ai
l'impression que j'ai changé hormis
peut-être l'abbaye en bien en biens a
enlevé le dernier fils bulls et le xiii
va très bien las bas il était guéri qui
s'est fait opéré du cerveau cdh écolo
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais alors la semaine dernière c'était
aussi le retour des jeux sur le plateau
oui car il ne l'oublions pas tmp est une
émission de coiffure médias et le centre
de loisirs
ce jour là le happening était simple
pour qu'un côté de la table puisse
répondre là il fallait qu'un objet passe
le plus vite possible de main en main
dans le public
ouais bon ça a pas l'air clair comme ça
mais avec des images ça va être beaucoup
plus sympas revenir ça le mari gérard
lanvin dans une maison de retraite beau
parce qu'on partait par action
alors là c'était du savon oui que cyril
à manger juste après il a mangé après
bassin mais contemplez paraît que c'est
hyper dangereux
bah oui bien sûr avec de l'eau derrière
sur la transforme en bain moussant mais
les gars et moi j étais ouf donc il ya
eu du savon et après il ya eu du jus
d'orange et beurre et c'est là où je
veux en venir
pour rendre hommage à cette dame dans le
public qui était au début de la chaîne
avec sa plaquette de beurre juste au
moment où s'il a décidé de faire une
pause dans le jeu va garder un bon
souvenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la neige la carte thermique sera
encore en février le premier tout chaud
je t'aimais je vous dire j'ai jamais
vraiment de tels commentaires sur
l'émission engine ans s'est arrêtée mais
télé loisirs art prison ni vraiment que
les gens avaient adoré l'émission je
pense qu'il ya une erreur de
programmation la chose que franchement
c'est un peu c'est un peu l'école des
fans 2.0 et une partie du public gagnant
à quelque chose pareil pour l'ebit
d'eads magnifique voix ce pays rochon
c'est vrai que les émissions
enregistrées
[Musique]
la peau de chagrin
j'aimerais qu'on retrouve cette dame qui
est charmante et je lui offre son poids
en boeuf c'est vrai je ne rigole pas et
était très joli regard des mamies qui
fait une blague a dit elle avait mis sa
fin la grande masse non c'est bien
franchement c'est pas seulement bien le
beurre et l'argent du beurre en même
temps dans l'ancien merci non mais ça a
été beaucoup plus drôle à vous et vous à
mon avis vous ne sortirez pas de bonnes
balles chaque année 1 passe et ses
besoins une formation ah oui oui bref
une promotion
j'ai besoin d'information vous les
nouveaux professeurs est-ce que vous ne
pas être mon professeur on va prenez
quelques ballons il va commencer à voir
basta cosi
il fallait du culot slides quand est ce
que je vais faire oui là quand on va
faire la pause à 2 5 minutes déjà
je vous ferai pour la prochaine demi
heure et la bam bam
il n'y aura pas deux snipers mais trois
dans cette émission
ça me plaît du boulot en plus il a une
oreillette
c'est vrai juste pour les personnes me
souffle rien alors là je suis pas très
bien bavard session et on commence par
ce jour où maxime gainey avait été
contraint de donner son oreillette à
matthieu delormeau alors bizarrement
juste après sans oreillettes et il y
avait beaucoup moins parler dans
l'émission ça va ce qui bien sûr avait
inquiété c'est gentil collègues
au contraire
si vous arrive je vous dis la vérité de
doudi il nous arrive de dire des bêtises
ici et il doit le regretter après ses
rangs j'ai plus le pipi d'ariane brodier
heureusement c'est tout dire quelque
chose
[Musique]
tout vrai ta gueule comme un mouton
maxime et kelly va faire un tour vous
allez voir et je me pense voilà qu'ils
arrêtent un tour bien sûr restituer les
côtés
[Musique]
quoi on peut pas du tout retirer l'eau
je suis cool pendant direct aussi j'ai
envie de faire quelque chose excusez-moi
de shopping non mais en vrai ça
s'appelle les monstres du shopping mais
l'adaptation d'un format tueur regarder
une petite compil
[Applaudissements]
on le costume qui va avec l'émission qui
vient d'en bas on à bernard de
l'indendie laverdière
ils viennent à ce petit jeu puis à
déterminer ce qu'est une bonne
prestation d'une très bonne prestation
c'est parce que t'as pas l'oreille
musicale
parce que t'as pas l'oreille musicale
[Musique]
j'ai eu des verts